j'ai adoré vous faire une vidéo sur les
papas alors je pouvais pas ne pas vous
faire une vidéo sur les mamans
évidemment chacun sa propre définition
d'une maman par exemple selon moi une
maman c'est cette personne qui met un
sandwich dans ton sac sans qu'ils s'en
rendent compte
celle qui te fait porter de très très
beau pull selon elle celle qui veut
absolument tu t'habilles très chaudement
même s'il fait déjà très chaud celle qui
essuient un truc sur ton visage mais
avec sa salive celle qui est très fière
de toi pour des choses dont toi tu es
pas très fier celle qui fait secrètement
une collection de tupperware celle qui
sait mieux que toi où sont rangées de
tes propres affaires celle qui écrit ton
nom et prénom est partout sur tes
affaires celle dont on a besoin dans les
moments où tu sais pas comment faire
celle qui même au bout du monde enverra
un message pour te dire j'ai slept
affiner tout et légumes un sms que laura
écrit uniquement avec l'index celle qui
est tellement dans ton esprit quand
courtade jadis maman eu madame leuthard
madame g
en tout cas toutes ces mamans on en a
besoin mais parfois celle inverse
c'est elle qui ont besoin de nous et
c'est souvent pour les mêmes choses
matteo ont mais comment l'application
internet
est ce que tu peux brancher une
imprimante j'aimerais imprimés google
maps matteo des branches la boxe là j'ai
mal à la tête à cause du wifi j'ai perdu
mon carnet où j'écris les numéros des
gens là tu peux m'aider
comment on envoie un texto bon matteo
enlèvement internet là j'ai besoin de
téléphoner
matteo tu peux me donner un coup c'est
bon écoute ce que je vais faire ses jeux
directement amenées à conseiller
technique qui va répondre à tout
problème
alors j'ai reçu un message jackie et
michel les mamans elles sont souvent
aussi de très bonnes comédiennes comme
par exemple quand il s'agit de faire
semblant d'être contente tu m'offres à
collier de nouilles remercie mon avis
c'est trop mignon
écoute moi cette année j'ai voulu être
aussi généreuse que toi alors je t'offre
un ipad un ipad en haut lieu voilà y'a
pas de charger sa marque direct les
mamans elles ont du pouvoir sur toi
elles savent comment te mettre la
pression avec des phrases du genre tu
descends dont j'ai maintenant je compte
jusqu'à 3 à 1
d'ailleurs quand tu as toujours rien
fait à deux elle met une petite rallonge
deux ennemis presque trois mois nicolas
les mamans elles ont toujours envie de
s'immiscer dans ta vie sentimentale de
manière gênante et ai donné des conseils
sur tes relations intimes
chez chloé ste rencontre bientôt un
petit copain qui pourra demander à maman
des petits conseils techniques
si tu veux dans les moindres détails
mais pas de souci ça va j'ai pas besoin
de conseils merci où le groupe hublot
somme ohkubo paquereau sur moi quand
j'étais petit je pensais que les parents
et faisait l'amour qu'une seule fois
dans leur vie pour avoir un enfant
et puis j'ai grandi et je me suis rendu
compte que c'était plutôt absurde
serra cac papa dès que vous faites
l'amour vous avez un enfant normal
voilà pourquoi ton père est moins lourd
9600 enfants et oui on adore les enfants
où on adore faire l'amour n'a qu'à
penser à l'amour
[Musique]
ferme ta gueule après il ya les mamans
hyper-protectrices celles qui sont
prêtes à tout pour protéger leurs
enfants de la moindre image néfaste
selon elle à leur éducation
chloé je t'interdis de regarder swing
jazz swing tu as encore faire plein
cauchemar
mais plutôt les infos on s'est beaucoup
plus constructif en syrie images atroces
de ses enfants qui se font décapité sur
les fleuves public le sang coule à flot
c'est vraiment wen en premier plutôt
stirling en fait regard toute la saison
il ya des mamans qui t'aime tellement
qu'elles sont prêtes est confectionné
des trucs alors c'est hyper mignon à
part quand c'est halloween et que ta
mère a fait en costume moi je me
souviens de ce fameux halloween 2 mai 11
ans mettez déguise en quoi mon sac
poubelle dans celle que tu nous aurons
qui a fabriqué ma mère heureusement
l'année suivante ma mère c'était bien
rattrapé en s'appliquant vraiment sur
mon costume de spiderman
m&t déguisant sacs poubelles rouge et
maman elles ont aussi le rôle de nous
disputer quand on fait une connerie ça
c'est quand même la base mais
heureusement la manière de punir les
enfants elle a quand même pas mal changé
1 depuis l'ancienne époque maman d'avant
non tu fais quoi
orion je fais pipi nobu de lanières du
martinez pour sa phase plus mal quand je
te frapperaient avec pour tenir à hockey
n'est quelques mois je vais faire un
détour la ballade à ce qu'a pensé un
fils de chien c'est ma maman
d'aujourd'hui enzo arrête tout de suite
sinon je te je te fait rien du tout je
te dispute verbalement c'est pas bien
les gorges sa soeur oui il ya un truc
qui me faisait toujours flipper quand
j'étais petit c'était comme ma mère
m'appelait non pas par mon diminutif
mais par mon nom complet
norman jay qui s'il est avant
alors qu'au début oui mais oui mon
deuxième prénom c'est jacky on va pas en
faire une histoire c'est quand je pense
à une place près ça aurait pu être mon
premier prénom ma vie aurait été un peu
différente
ah bon on va pas trop se moquer non plus
du prêt dont jacky puisque c'est
également le prénom de mon père quand et
ados ya toujours un moment où tu te
rebelle contre ta mère et à ce moment là
tu as envie de prouver au monde entier
que tu as plus besoin d'elle face aux
dieux ne comprendra jamais tu le
méritais j'ai fait en fait j'ai réfléchi
et je t'aime trop il a valu à téter
partie elle va mettre l'adaptable est
malheureusement tout le monde n'a pas
une famille modèle avec un papa et une
maman qui s'aiment
maintenant il ya plein de familles
recomposées et c'est vrai que l'un des
moments les plus délicats sans doute
c'est quand une maman annonce à ses
enfants à qu'elle fréquente un nouvel
homme tu vois timothée des plus beaux
moments les plus avec papa et bien à
l'envoi d'autres hommes forte que je te
présente
rang
et bruno et fabrice jau thimoté pour
conclure cette vidéo j'aimerais vous
dire un truc tout simple tellement
simple on oublie parfois que c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus important
mais dans la vie ce mal plus cher ça se
trouve pas dans les bouquins sur le net
voilà bout du monde
non ce n'est plus cher ça se trouve
juste là à côté nous nos familles nos
proches et parfois on les voit même pas
où on se dit qu'on a toute la vie pour
leur dire je t'aime et ça c est faux
alors si vous avez la chance dans votre
maman à vos côtés et simplement
profitez-en chaque jour chaque minute
chaque seconde et prouver lui tout votre
amour parce que vous n'avez qu'une
[Musique]
je
il
[Musique]